MALE SPEAKER: How
many people here are
entirely new to meditation?
OK, cool, a few.
How many people here are new to
compassion and heart practices
flavor of meditation?
OK, cool.
How many people are
horrified and scared
at the idea of sitting
for 45 minutes straight?
It's OK to be honest.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
SHARON SALZBERG:
Sitting where you are.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, so there
were two brave people
who raised their hands.
I'm going to guess that there's
probably like a 3x or 4x shame
reduction factor.
So what we might
do is we might--
SHARON SALZBERG:
We'll break it up.
MALE SPEAKER: We'll
break it up a little bit.
We'll do 20 minutes
of one flavor
and then 20 minutes
of another flavor
and leave the option for
Q&A if people want to.
But if there's no
questions, we can also
just hold the Q&A until the end.
So does that work for everyone?
All right, that sounds cool.
All right.
You want to jump in?
SHARON SALZBERG: Sure.
Hello.
Thank you again for
this invitation.
It's so great to be here.
MALE SPEAKER: Excellent.
SHARON SALZBERG:
Makes me very happy.
And for Lindsey, who
put in so much work,
I'm sure, to make it all happen,
and to all of you for coming.
So what we thought we
would do was really
what was just described.
I'll give a very,
very brief overview
of different kinds of
meditation, and we'll do one,
and we'll take a break and
see if you have any questions
or comments in that break.
And maybe not.
And then we'll go on
and do the other kind,
and then we'll just have fun
together and dialogue and being
together, and further questions.
So I went to India to
learn meditation in 1970.
I'd taken an Asian
philosophy course
in the university
I was going to,
and the university
also had a program,
like an independent
study program.
And if you created a
project that they liked,
you could go anywhere
in the world.
And I had this kind
of strange desire
to learn how to meditate.
So I created a project.
I said, I want to go to
India and learn mediation.
And they said OK, so off I went.
I came back in 1974 with the
encouragement and, actually,
insistence of one of
my teachers to teach.
So I came back as a teacher.
So that was really the
beginning of many things.
And in those days, one never
heard the word mindfulness.
And if you said you
were-- as I would
in some social
situation-- people
would say, what do you do?
And I'd say, teach meditation.
It would be kind of
like, ew, that's weird.
Which is very,
very different now.
So there are lots of ways
of slicing and dicing
and categorizing
meditation practice.
I always think of meditation
is a skills training,
and primarily in three
different qualities.
One is concentration,
so that we're
less scattered or
distracted-- less fragmented.
We feel more of a sense
of presence and wholeness
and focus.
One is mindfulness
itself, which feels
like the word of the hour.
Classically, it means
a quality of attention
so that as we pay
attention, our perception's
not so distorted by bias.
We're not laying on so many
preconceptions or old fears
or assumptions, and
we can get much closer
to our experience in that
way, without so many veils
intruding.
And therefore, mindfulness
is considered the basis
for insight or wisdom, because
we can get so much more
connected to things as they
actually are when we're not,
for example, taking the present
moment's experience of it's
difficult and projecting it into
a seemingly unchanging future,
like, what's this terrible thing
going to feel like in a week?
It's going to be
worse, you know?
And so on.
So that's really the
skill of mindfulness.
And then compassion
and loving kindness
is like the third great
skill of meditation,
and it is considered a
skill, which is often
in the West considered
kind of peculiar.
It's a little bit kind of cold
or mechanistic in some ways,
we think, like the idea
of training and compassion
is just offputting.
And I don't know if
it's that we tend
to think of
compassion as a gift,
and you've either got it or you
don't, and if you don't, you're
out of luck.
Or it's like a seemingly
spontaneous emotional response,
and there's nothing you can do.
But another way of looking
at it from the point of view
of meditation is
that compassion is
like an emergent property
of how we pay attention.
And if we shift the way we pay
attention-- so, for example,
we're not overlooking someone
or looking through them
or discounting
them, we're actually
looking at them-- then because
of that different quality
of attention, there will be a
different sense of connection,
and therefore, compassion.
So it, too, is a kind
of attention training.
So in terms of the
larger ways of practice,
there's some practices
that really are largely
about cultivating mindfulness,
where our goal is not
to have a particular
experience at all,
but to change our relationship
to whatever experience comes up
so we're more present,
we're more aware,
we're more balanced, and there's
more insight that can develop.
And that's the first practice
that we're going to do.
Many of you, I'm sure,
are very familiar with it.
A very classic
practice where you
start with awareness of the
breath, which is certainly
not the only way to
lay a foundation,
but it's such a
common way in part
because as my early teachers
would say, first of all,
you don't have to
believe anything
in order to feel your breath.
It's not tied to any kind
of dogma or faith tradition
or lack of faith tradition.
If you're breathing,
you can be meditating.
And then as one teacher said-- I
always found it very charming--
he said the breath
is very portable.
So, you know, we come together.
It's like a formal,
determined sitting.
OK, now I'm going to come
together and sit with people.
And we get used to
coming back to the moment
and coming back
to ourselves using
the vehicle of the breath.
And then you're
at work, or you're
in traffic, or whatever it is.
You have that
means of returning.
And the other set
of practices, which
we'll do next, while they
involve, to a certain degree,
the development of
mindfulness and a greater
clarity about our
experience, I call them
sort of like the stretch.
And that is the
sense of realizing
that our attention can be highly
habituated in certain ways,
and we're just going
to see what it's like.
It's like an experiment.
We're going to see
what it's like when
we step outside the confines
of that ordinary way of paying
attention.
And that's that whole group of
concentration practices based
on compassion and love
and kindness and so on.
They're not meant to be
pretentious and weird and
phony, which is
often the feeling.
Like, ew.
That's a little offputting.
But in truth, I think
they're pretty radical,
because it's like taking
some risks with our awareness
in ways we don't necessarily do.
So, for example, if you
think about that person
you normally look right
through, because they
don't count in some way,
what happens when you look
at them instead of through them?
Or if you're the kind of person
who at the end of the day
is looking back at
yourself through the day,
and you pretty well only
remember the mistakes you made,
and the things you didn't
do really perfectly,
and what you could have done
better, let's just say--
AUDIENCE: I have no idea
what you're talking about.
SHARON SALZBERG:
No one ever does.
And then the stretch
is not to pretend, oh,
I had a perfect day and did
everything magnificently,
but not to be limited
by that, right?
To include also, wow, I
have that to be grateful,
or I did that well, or
there was that goodness
in what came my way, right?
So both sets of practices--
the mindfulness practices
that help bring us closer to our
experience and those practices
which are like experimenting
with awareness--
are based on inclusion.
We include experiences
in a field of awareness.
We include more and more beings
in a field of connection.
OK?
So rather than my saying
more, we'll practice some,
and then we'll get
into some discussion.
So all right.
Don't look at that
clock, whatever you do.
AUDIENCE: The clock is a test.
SHARON SALZBERG:
So to begin with,
we're going to do a
sitting based primarily
on mindfulness practice.
And interestingly
enough, the core value
of this kind of practice
is said to be balance.
Unlike other pursuits
we might engage in
or other endeavors
we might have,
where we get into a
kind of acquisitive,
almost grabby kind
of mode-- like, well,
if I have a great sitting,
I can leave at the break.
Instead, the work is to bring
our system into greater balance
with the belief that
out of that balance
will come the insight and the
growth and awareness and so on,
so that some of that balance
is experienced right away
in our posture.
You want some
energy in your body.
You want to see if your
back can be straight.
But like so much energy.
You're really hypervigilant
and you're so uptight.
You also want to be
relaxed, but not, like,
so relaxed that you're
way slumped over
as though you
couldn't care less.
So see if you can feel
your way into what
feels like a balanced posture.
And you can close
your eyes or not.
However you feel most at ease.
If your eyes are open, they
can also be a little bit open.
You can find a spot
to rest your gaze.
Let it go.
And if you get really
sleepy, as sometimes happens
with your eyes closed, you
can also just open your eyes
and continue on.
Very often, we start
by listening to sound.
It's a way of
relaxing deep inside,
allowing our experience
to come and go.
And of course, we
like certain sounds
and we don't like others.
But we don't have to chase after
them to hold on or push away.
Just let them come, let them go.
It's like the sounds
wash through you.
And bring your attention to the
feeling of your body sitting.
Whatever sensations
you discover.
Bring your attention
to your hands.
See if you can make the shift
from the more conceptual level,
like of fingers, to the
world of direct sensation,
picking up pulsing, throbbing,
pressure, whatever it might be.
You don't have to name
those things, but feel them.
Now bring your attention to
the feeling of your breath.
In this system, it's just
the normal, natural breath,
wherever you feel
it most distinctly.
You don't have to try to make
the breath deeper or different.
See if there's a place where
it's strongest for you--
maybe at the nostrils or
the chest or the abdomen.
If you find that place, you
can bring your attention
there and just rest.
See if you can feel one breath.
Without concern
for what's already
gone by, without leaning forward
for even the very next breath.
Just this one.
If you like, you can use
a very quiet mental note,
like in, out, or rising,
falling to help support
the awareness of the breath.
But very quiet.
So your attention
is really going
to feeling the breath
one breath at a time.
And if sounds or images,
sensations or emotions
should arise, but they're
not all that strong,
if you can stay connected to
the feeling of the breath,
just let them flow on by.
You're breathing.
It's just one breath.
But if something
is really strong,
and you get lost in thought,
spun out in a fantasy,
or you fall asleep,
you get really
disconnected from the
breath, don't worry about it.
We say the most important
moment in the whole practice
is the moment after
you've been gone,
after you've been distracted.
That's the moment where the
training actually takes place.
We practice letting go gently.
We practice beginning again.
Maybe you have to do it
again 10 seconds later.
Doesn't matter.
We let go.
We begin again.
Just shepherd your
attention back
to the feeling of the breath.
And if you have to do
that a few billion times
in the next few
minutes, it's OK.
Isn't that amazing
that no matter
what happens, we can
always begin again?
Maybe you went far far, far
away for a good long time.
It's OK.
It's what one of
my teachers called
exercising the
letting go muscle.
We practice letting go,
and with a full heart,
not feeling diminished or
that we failed, we start over.
[CHIMING]
SHARON SALZBERG:
That's my new bell.
I had to use it.
It's so beautiful.
OK, do you have any questions
about anything you experienced,
or anything I said,
or any comments?
And then we'll go on.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I was wondering if you could
talk to us a little more
about Di Pama and [INAUDIBLE].
SHARON SALZBERG: OK,
so the question was,
since I had used the phrase
my teacher or my teachers,
especially I had one teacher--
this woman named Di Pama, who
was not famous, and she
was not a celebrity.
Somebody wrote a book about her.
The second version of it, I
think, is called "Di Pama."
And it was very interesting,
because unlike some teachers,
she was most remarkable,
really, for her presence.
And so it was a little hard
to write a book about her,
because you didn't have the
illuminating sentence that
changed your whole life or
something that you really
wanted to be able to share.
But it was just, like, wow.
She was the most loving
person I ever met.
Di Pama was one of
my early teachers.
Di Pama is a nickname.
It means deep is mother.
And she was the person,
actually, who told me to teach.
She's the reason that
I became a teacher.
She was most impressive to me,
really, because of her story.
She was a woman who'd been
through tremendous suffering
in her own personal life.
She'd been put into an
arranged marriage when
she was 12 years old,
and she and her husband
actually fell deeply in love.
And then they didn't have
children for about 18 years.
And then they had
three children.
Two of her children died.
And then one day, her
husband died really suddenly.
He just wasn't feeling well,
and he died by that evening.
And she still has one
daughter, Dipa, to raise.
But she was completely
grief stricken.
She just went to bed.
She couldn't get out of bed.
And they were living in
Burma, because her husband
had been in the civil service.
And the doctor came to see
her, and he said to her,
you're actually going
to die of a broken heart
unless you do something
about your mind.
You should learn
how to meditate.
And she got up out of bed and
she went to the retreat center,
and she learned how to meditate.
And when she emerged,
it's like she'd
taken all of that suffering
and all of that pain
and she'd turned it
into enormous compassion
for everybody.
And she was just the most
loving, amazing person,
because she knew for all of us,
our lives can change on a dime,
and there was no one left
out of her sense of love
and connection, in a very
ordinary kind of way, you know?
Like, oh, did you
have enough tea?
Would you like some more tea?
And the lack of
self-preoccupation
was so remarkable, because
I'd often look at her
and think, well, if I'd
been through what you've
been through, would I care
about someone else's tea?
Maybe not, you know?
But she'd used all that
in a beautiful way.
So when she told me
to teach, it was 1974,
and I went to say goodbye
to her in Calcutta.
I was coming back for
what I was absolutely
convinced was a very brief
return to the United States
before I went back to India
to live the rest of my life
there being a student.
And she said, when you go back
to America, you'll be teaching.
And I said, no I won't.
And she said, yes you will.
And I said no I won't.
And then she said two things
that were really extraordinary.
One was, she said, you
really understand suffering.
That's why you should teach.
And I had never thought
of like the personal pain
I had gone through as having
been a credential for anything,
really, you know?
You really understand suffering.
That's why you should teach.
And then she said, you can
do anything you want to do.
It's just you're
thinking you can't do it
that's going to stop you.
And I left her room
thinking, no I won't.
And I came back to the US
and began teaching and more
invitations would come and
more invitations would come,
and one day we established
this retreat center
in Massachusetts.
And somewhere after
that, I thought, oh, I
guess I'm not going back
there to live after all.
I guess I live here now.
Anybody else?
Maybe I'll use her, which is a
wonderful feeling, thank you,
as the introduction for the
loving kindness meditation.
Because I think also,
in this society,
we can think of kindness
and loving-- loving
kindness is a weird word anyway.
We don't necessarily use it.
But even compassion,
as weakness.
I mean, someone told me
if you google compassion,
very quickly,
fatigue will come up.
Compassion fatigue.
We think of kindness often
as a secondary virtue.
It's like, if you
can't be brilliant,
and you can't be courageous,
and you can't be wonderful,
eh, be kind.
You know?
It's nice.
It's not great, but
it's good, you know?
It's good enough, kind of.
But I think of somebody like
Di Pama, and it's great.
It's a great, great
thing to encounter
that kind of caring energy
from somebody, where you really
feel they're not in
it for themselves.
They're just wanting to help or
be there or be present, or just
energetically, that
field is so amazing.
And I don't think of her
with a kind of scorn,
like, eh, you couldn't do
anything else with your life,
so you became loving, you know?
It's like, it's a very different
quality of appreciation
that I think we actually
do have when we think maybe
about people we've
encountered or so on.
So one of the problems
with mindfulness practice
is the word, and the words
that get associated with it,
like accept things
the way they are.
You going to be
with your experience
without judgement that can sound
so passive and so complacent,
like you're just going to
sit there no matter what.
And so it takes a
real exploration
to understand it's a
dynamic, vital relationship.
Like, once I was
teaching somewhere,
and I started the
instructions in the same way.
Like, sit and listen to sound.
And somebody immediately
raised their hand
and said, well, what if it's
the sound of the smoke alarm
I hear?
Should I sit here and be mindful
of the sound of the smoke
alarm, or should I get up?
And I said, I'd get up.
But just hearing the words, I
want to accept things the way
they are, can sound a little
dull, you know, like that.
And of course, there
are tremendous problems
with words like loving kindness,
and kindness, and compassion.
And I think it demands that
same kind of exploration
and experimentation to get a
deeper sense of what's meant.
I think of loving kindness
as an acknowledgement--
a very deep acknowledgement--
of the connection that exists.
It doesn't mean that
you like somebody.
It doesn't mean you're
going to take them home.
going to give them
all your money, or any money.
It means this almost like
bone deep acknowledgement
that our lives have something
to do with one another.
And so many things bring
us to that understanding.
Certainly, environmental
consciousness brings us there.
Even epidemiology
brings us there.
Economics brings us there.
What happens over there
doesn't nicely stay over there.
It ripples out over here.
And what we do, it
matters, because
of those waves of connection.
It's just the nature of things.
And so it's not always
pleasant, but it's true
that our lives have something
to do with one another.
And the lead lived of that,
the heart's response to that,
is what we mean by
loving kindness.
It doesn't mean you're forcing a
certain feeling or emotion that
isn't really there at all.
It's more that sensibility, that
real, real sense that everybody
counts.
Everybody matters.
Maybe my favorite expression
of loving kindness
came when I was teaching
in Washington, DC.
It was in this rented space
which was an elementary school.
And they had the
rules of kindness
on these sheets of
paper along the wall.
And my favorite, favorite
rule of kindness-- it
was things like respect
everyone on the inside
and on the outside.
But my favorite
rule of all of them
was, everybody gets to play.
Everybody gets to play.
Everybody is not my best friend,
but everybody gets to play.
So that's very much the
sense of loving kindness.
And we practice in
the way I described--
not forcing a feeling or trying
to pretend you feel something
you don't, but kind of
stretching our awareness
to pay attention to the
people we usually ignore,
to consider the good
within ourselves instead
of only the mistakes we've made.
We kind of play with our
awareness in various ways
to see what might then
follow in the nature of care
and compassion.
So in this practice, instead
of centering our attention
around the feeling
of the breath,
we center our attention
around the silent repetition
of certain phrases.
The phrases may not be
the most predominant thing
in any given moment.
That's fine.
You may have a very
strong sense of the being
you're offering
loving kindness to.
You may have an emotion,
or not, coming up.
But the phrases are
like the bottom line.
It's what we can
keep returning to,
to have a place to
rest our attention.
And the phrases are the
conduit for our attention.
It's the way we're paying
attention in a different way.
The phrases are words,
and therefore they're
going to be imperfect,
so I usually suggest
to people, choose good
enough phrases so they're not
bothering you.
Even if they don't seem
absolutely perfect,
the idea is to choose phrases
that are kind of general so
that you're not constantly
thinking, like, what about you?
Maybe happy?
Well, I don't know about you.
Like, you get really
lazy when you're happy.
Maybe content.
No, content's even worse.
It's just like, because
the power of the practice
is going to be from
the gathering of all
of our attention behind
one phrase at a time.
We want to keep
things simple, right?
Again, it's like
letting go and returning
is the movement of the practice.
And that's how it develops,
through paying attention
in different ways.
The construct-- the grammatical
construct of the phrases--
is usually may I and may you.
May I be happy, may I be
peaceful, may you be happy,
may you be peaceful.
Some people don't like that.
It sounds too much like
pleading or imploring.
One of my friends
told me-- she told me
it was the hortatory
subjunctive part of speech,
and she said it's like, you
hand someone a birthday card,
and you say, may you
have a happy birthday.
May you have a great new year.
It's a blessing.
It's a giving.
It's actually a
generosity practice.
It's gift giving.
We're giving ourselves
that quality of energy.
We're giving someone else
OK, so the basic bookends
of doing the practice
are starting with
yourself, and ending
with the extension of loving
kindness to all beings
everywhere to all of life.
And what you do in the
middle might be different
all the time.
Maybe you have a friend
who's in trouble,
so you want to include them.
Or someone you feel
very grateful to,
and you want to include them.
Or whatever it might be.
So I'll guide you through
just one variation
of the many possibilities
of doing it.
So again, if you
sit comfortably,
and you can close
your eyes or not.
Let your energy
settle into your body.
See if there are three
or four phrases that
work for you as that
sense of gift giving
for yourself, and
ultimately for others.
Common phrases are things
like may I be happy,
may I be peaceful.
May I live with ease, which
means in the things of day
to day life, like
livelihood and family,
may it not be a struggle.
May I live with ease.
May I be happy.
May I be peaceful.
May I live with
ease, or whatever
phrases you want to use.
And just gently repeat
them over and over again
with enough space
and enough silence
so that it's a rhythm
that's pleasing to you.
All kinds of feelings
may come and go, or none.
It doesn't matter.
The power of the practice is
in that complete wholehearted
presence behind one
phrase at a time.
Now think of somebody who is
like an embodiment of loving
kindness and compassion.
Maybe you've met them.
Maybe you haven't.
Maybe they exist
now or historically
or even mythically.
And imagine that being offering
loving kindness to you.
Now put yourself in the
position of the recipient.
And again, all kinds
of feelings may come.
You may feel embarrassed.
You might feel entitled.
All kinds of things.
But let them wash through you
as you steady your attention
on the repetition
of the phrases.
Maybe it's that
being or someone else
comes to mind who's been
like a mentor for you,
a benefactor for you.
They've helped pick you up
when you've fallen down,
or maybe they've
inspired you from afar.
And if someone like
that comes to mind,
you can bring them here.
Get an image of them.
Say their name to yourself.
Get a feeling for their
presence and offer
the phrases of loving
kindness to them.
Give them that same gift.
Again, even if the
words are imperfect,
it's OK, because they're the
conduit for the heart's energy.
And then a friend.
The first friend
who comes to mind.
Bring them here.
Again, you can get
an image of them,
or say their name to yourself.
Get a feeling for their
presence and offer
the phrases of loving
kindness to them.
And then everybody here,
including yourself.
May we be happy.
May we be peaceful.
May we live with ease.
Or whatever phrases
you may be using.
And then all beings everywhere.
All people, all
creatures, all those
in existence near and
far, known and unknown.
May all beings be happy, be
peaceful, live with ease.
SHARON SALZBERG: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
SHARON SALZBERG: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Does anybody have any questions
about how the practice went,
and then we'll just pass
this around as needed?
SHARON SALZBERG: OK.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE].
I get the basic
idea, but I always
had this nagging question which
is that-- especially if you're
talking about creatures
instead of just humans, well,
some creatures are going to
be eating other creatures.
SHARON SALZBERG: I know.
AUDIENCE: And so
they're not both
going to be happy
at the same time.
[LAUGHTER]
SHARON SALZBERG: I need to
repeat the question, right?
Yes, so the question was kind
of a discomfort at the offering
of loving kindness
to all beings,
because it's basically
illogical, that especially
when you're offering
loving kindness,
say, to all creatures, since
creatures eat other creatures,
they're not all going to
be happy at the same time.
That is totally true.
Sometimes I think of loving
kindness practice as landing us
right in the center
of a paradox.
And sometimes I think of
it as it's meant, really,
to the arena of transformation
of loving kindness practice is
our field of intention.
It's how we are relating
in terms of inclusion
and exclusion, in terms
of noticing or ignoring,
in terms of opening
or shutting off.
So that's the transformation,
and so that's our test.
It's not easy, and it's
not going to happen.
But nonetheless, our
own commitment in life
is to include
rather than exclude,
and to recognize the
suffering of beings.
That is a part of nature.
It's a part of life.
And to ourselves, not
be causing more harm,
to the best of our
ability, and so on.
And also, it brings us to what's
a really exquisite balance
that's often talked about
between, say, loving kindness
and compassion on the
one side, and just
equanimity on the other.
It's like, yeah, this
is the way things are.
And there's a kind
of poignancy in that.
in that I often
say and feel it's
too bad it's not my
universe to control,
because it might be
better if it were,
or at least I think it would be.
But it's not.
Whether it's an immediate
situation-- one on one
with a friend or colleague,
or it's kind of more
a global look at the
nature of things.
We want beings to be happy,
and we can't make it so.
And yet we need to
do what we can do.
That's not a call for passivity.
But what we do needs to
be done in that context
of understanding, you know?
You can't make it so.
Yeah.
Do you want to--
AUDIENCE: You use
the same-- is it on?
MALE SPEAKER: We'll just
repeat the question.
AUDIENCE: You used
the same phrases
as you progressed through
the different categories
of [INAUDIBLE].
Is that a suggestive
practice or would you
alter those for a
particular [INAUDIBLE]?
SHARON SALZBERG:
So the comment was
that I had used the
same phrases as we moved
through different
categories, and so is
that the suggestion,
or would you alter them
as different beings
come to mind?
Well, here's a balance point,
which is very interesting,
I think.
In any meditation,
there's a balance
that's talked about between
tranquility and calm
and concentration
on the one side,
and alertness and
energy and kind
of aliveness on the other side.
And we're always working
with that balance,
because we want both.
We want to be more
tranquil and calm,
but not so tranquil and
calm that we're in a stupor.
And we want to be alert and
interested and connected
and learning and
investigating, but not
so much so that we get
agitated and restless.
So in every technique
and every method,
we work around that balance.
And especially sometimes in
loving kindness practice,
because it's so active, and
because these are real beings,
and relationships
are complicated,
I tend to encourage
a lot of work
on the kind of tranquility,
calm, concentration side,
because there's almost nothing
easier in that practice than
to go off with a lot
of energy and a story.
Like, well, I thought
you were my benefactor,
and it worked for a while, but
then I remembered that one time
when I called you and you
weren't really there for me.
So maybe you're
not my benefactor.
Maybe you're my difficult
person, you know?
Maybe you're in
the wrong category.
I don't have any benefactors.
Oh no, I'm so forlorn.
You know?
It's very easy, because
relationships are complicated.
We're complicated.
And so we're bringing that
right into the meditative arena.
And so it's not to the
exclusion of having
that aliveness
and kind of spark.
It could never be.
But I just think it's good
to have a sense of structure
and simplicity that we
can keep returning to.
And so that would argue
for the same phrases,
so you're not sitting
there thinking,
what was my phrasing again?
And yet, sometimes, someone
will come to mind and almost
bring their own
phrases with them.
So you just switch.
It's not going to be one
of those agitated sessions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
SHARON SALZBERG: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Thanks. for coming.
So, when you talked
about the comparison
between loving kindness
mediation and mindfulness
practice, do you find that
the difference between the two
is different end goals
in mind, or strictly
personal preference, or
when there is a good time
to use one compared to another?
SHARON SALZBERG: OK,
so the difference
between mindfulness practice
and loving kindness practice,
and do they have
different goals in mind,
or just different kind
of styles of practice?
And when is a good time
to use one or the other?
They are actually designed for
different goals in many ways,
but not to the complete
exclusion of the other.
It's almost like
there's a primary goal,
and then there are all
those attendant results
or consequences that
will come along.
So the primary goal of
mindfulness practice
is said to be insight or wisdom.
When something arises in us, and
we're not struggling against it
right away, there's more
chance for learning, right?
And at the same time, if
something arises in us,
and we're not falling into it
completely right away-- like,
I'm such an angry person.
I will be forever.
There's a lot more
room for learning.
So mindfulness is all
about relationships,
and it's establishing a
relationship to our experience
so that insight can flower.
One of the things we
have insight into,
just because it happens
to be the way it is,
is connection or
interconnection.
The way we perceive self
and other and us them
we see as a construct.
That's an insight.
We see that we do live in
an interdependent universe.
That everybody does
matter, even if we
don't like everybody
or anybody, that we
live as part of a network
as well as an individual.
That's true.
And so the more
we see that, just
in the course of
developing insight,
the more loving kindness
will come all by itself.
But you may also have insights
into all kinds of other things.
And that's really what
the mindfulness practice
is designed for.
And loving kindness
practice is really
designed to-- first of all,
it's an antidote to fear.
And it's about
inclusion in attention,
and really broadening
the way we pay attention.
What do we pay attention to?
Who do we pay attention to?
What's the quality
of that attention?
And the primary one
purpose of it, or benefit,
will be the experience
of loving kindness.
It's really a
different way of being.
It's like, just as an
example, friends of mine who
are performers tell me
that one in particular
had terrible stage fright.
And so she would commonly
get up on the stage,
and she'd look out
at those people who
she knew were just
sitting there waiting
to judge her mercilessly,
and really be afraid of them,
and really dislike them.
And then she get more
and more uptight.
And so there was this
huge sense of, like,
the other is out there
just waiting to get me.
So she got in the habit
of getting up on the stage
and doing loving
kindness practice.
And then it was different.
It wasn't that she got sloppy
or didn't care anymore,
but there was almost a sense
like, OK, we're here together.
And I know that
even if one makes
a mistake in that
kind of atmosphere,
it's different, right?
It's a different
sense of connection.
sense of community.
So that would be where loving
kindness practice goes.
Along the way, there's
a lot of insight.
It just happens because you're
paying attention, right?
And you're also
stretching your attention,
so you see, ooh, I didn't know
that I had this power of love,
or I didn't know that
this was arising in me,
and I pulled back because
I was so embarrassed.
Or I didn't know that this
person who I really don't like
is not just the enemy.
I used to spend all my time
when thinking about them going
through the same
list of their faults.
It wasn't like I
found new faults.
It was just the same list
again and again and again.
Look what happens when I
actually broaden my attention.
I still think they're not that
great in all those arenas,
but look at that.
There's also this.
Or what if this?
Somebody told me
this story after I'd
written my most recent
book about work,
and she said that she got into
the habit of starting meetings
just by silently looking
at everybody in the room
and reminding herself,
you know, everybody here
wants to be happy.
Everybody actually
They might have different
definitions or ways
of approaching it, but everybody
actually wants to be happy.
So it's something like that.
So certainly,
there are insights,
and we utilize them from
loving kindness practice.
It's just the main
emphasis is different.
And I think it's
great to do both.
You know?
It's not like an either/or
in terms of methodology.
A lot of people do both,
and they just experiment.
These days, when I sit,
which is every day, which
we can talk about, my
practice-- my formal practice--
is really mindfulness practice.
But I have a commitment to
do loving kindness practice
whenever I'm waiting.
And I count every mode of
transportation as waiting.
So every airplane,
every taxi, walking down
the streets of New York.
I silently keep repeating
those phrases for myself,
or for someone I'm encountering.
And it's so much more
fun than what I'm usually
doing on an airplane,
whatever that is.
And it's a whole
other way of being.
And you think about
all those times
during the day when we just
kind of filling in the time,
and think about not doing
that, but actually doing
some loving kindness practice.
There are lots of ways of
bringing them together.
Do you want--
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we
can jump into some others.
And for part of this
more conversational part,
about the application of
this kind of meditation,
it's really important
that you guys
feel comfortable sort of
joining in the conversation.
So if you want to
take the conversation
a certain direction, feel free.
And we can do that.
But I'd like to throw
one more question
in about the actual mechanics
of the practice itself.
I've been on heart
practice retreats,
and there was someone
in the corner who's
getting over some
childhood trauma
and really having
a breakthrough,
and very obviously being
really emotional about it.
I think it's easy to have an
expectation with this practice
of having a strong
emotional response.
Can you speak to the
idea of what should one
expect while you're
doing this sort of thing?
SHARON SALZBERG:
The question was
what should one expect
while doing a heart
centered practice?
Well, I think that's a
fascinating question anyway,
and I think it's
crucial in terms
of being able to
continue a practice.
So I said that when I
first came back from India,
if I'd be at some
social situation,
people would say to
me, what do you do?
And I say, I teach meditation.
They'd kind of go, ew.
Well, nowadays, the single
most common response I hear
is, I'm so stressed out.
I could use some of that.
Or, I hear, what I
find very amusing,
my partner should
really meet you.
They could really
use some of that.
Or I hear, I tried it once.
I failed at it.
I tried to meditate.
I couldn't do it.
And they then describe
obviously what
they expected to have happen.
I failed at it, because I
couldn't stop my thinking.
I couldn't have only
beautiful thoughts.
I couldn't keep
sleepiness at bay.
I couldn't stop
from being restless.
Whatever it is.
And from the point of view
of meditation, none of that
is why we meditate.
You're not going to
stop your thoughts.
make your mind blank.
You're not going to have
only beautiful thoughts.
But you can change your
relationship to everything,
right?
That's the power we have.
And to beautiful experiences, to
painful experiences, all of it.
And so with loving
kindness, there's
its own set of expectations.
Either I should have beautiful
feeling and wonderful,
I should float away, I
should forgive myself totally
by this afternoon, I've put in
20 minutes, it should be over,
or I should have this
kind of huge catharsis.
I should feel this kind of
gooey, light, warm feeling
toward everybody.
And it's especially funny.
My first book was called
"Loving Kindness,"
and it's all about doing
loving kindness meditation.
And after that, people used
to say to me, what's it
like to love everybody all
the time without exception,
without hesitation?
And I go, huh.
I mean, I wrote a
book on it, but it
doesn't mean I'm perfect at it.
And so those
expectations are very
important to acknowledge, to
recognize and bring forth.
And I guarantee you you
can do loving kindness
practice in an ardent,
useful, transformative way,
and not have any
emotion happening.
You really can.
It's not that it
never happens, but I
see from my own experiences
and from teaching thousands
of people, this
kind of practice--
it's something deeper
than the level of emotion.
And sometimes it will
translate as emotion,
and sometimes it won't.
So my signature story about
loving kindness practice
is the first month we moved into
the Insight Meditation Society
in 1976.
We didn't have any
programming for a month.
So those of us who
were there decided,
oh, we'll just sit ourselves.
And I'd always wanted to do
loving kindness practice,
and I'd always done it a
little bit here and there,
but never systematically.
So I had a month, and I knew
you started with yourself
and then you moved on
to these categories.
So I spent the whole first week
doing loving kindness practice
for myself, and I felt
absolutely nothing.
It was a completely dreary week.
And then at the end of
the week, several of us
had to leave suddenly,
because something
happened to a friend
of ours in Boston.
So I was getting ready
to leave the retreat,
and I was up in one
of the bathrooms,
and I dropped this big jar of
something on the tile floor,
and the jar just went
down and shattered
and stuff went everywhere.
And I noticed the first
thought that came up in my mind
was, you are really a
klutz, but I love you.
And I thought, look at that.
You could have
given me anything,
and I could not
have honestly said
something was happening
during that week,
but something was happening.
And I've seen
thousands of times.
Which is one of the reasons
it's difficult for people
to continue their
meditation practice
is because I think
we tend to look
at the wrong place for results.
We need to look
at our lives, not
necessarily at that
20 minute period a day
where we may not have the great
breakthrough, or float away,
or whatever it is.
But we will be different.
MALE SPEAKER: So
let's talk about
the practical applications
of compassion.
So does compassion
make you a sucker?
What about assholes?
SHARON SALZBERG: Do I
need to repeat that?
MALE SPEAKER: No.
AUDIENCE: This means
the YouTube video
might get a parental warning.
SHARON SALZBERG: Oh, OK.
No, it does not
make you a sucker.
That is of great interest to
me, having this conversation,
because that, of course, is
what we think-- that you're
going to be too nice, you're
going to give too much,
or you're going
to get exhausted.
But I think a very
rigorous investigation,
and certainly in a
personal experiential level
of compassion shows us
it's not the same thing
as being devastated by
someone's situation,
because then we're
just exhausted.
We have nothing to give, right?
Years ago, I was teaching in the
Soviet Union, when it was still
the Soviet Union, and I'd
gone with my friend, Joseph
Goldstein, and a tour group--
because you couldn't go apart
from that in those days.
And every afternoon,
Joseph and I
would disappear, instead of
going to look at some museum,
and we'd go to someone's house
to teach with a translator.
And I was talking a
lot about compassion.
And I noticed that
every time I did
that, I'd just get
a sense of a really
funny feeling in the room.
And finally, I said
to the translator,
when I say compassion,
what do you say?
And they said, oh, it's this
state where you feel like,
broken by the
suffering, and nearly
destroyed by the
suffering, and it's
like someone has
taken a giant stake
and driven it
through your heart.
And I thought, well,
no wonder there's
a really funny
feeling in the room.
MALE SPEAKER: That
seems very Russian.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yes,
it is very Russian.
But we can go there
and imagine that that's
compassion, where that
is more like devastation.
Or we can think, oh, I'm just
going to give in too much.
I'm going to be too nice.
So the way we usually
distinguish it
is going back to
what I said before,
that loving kindness
and compassion
affect our field of motivation.
It's why we do things.
It isn't necessarily going to
determine what we do, right?
We might be coming
from a genuinely
loving and compassionate
place, but our sense
of discernment in a
particular situation,
in a particular context, might
be that we need to say no.
We need to be fierce.
We need to be kind of intense.
And that's going to be
based on wisdom, you know?
It's like our best
guess of what's
most appropriate
in that context.
But we don't have to be
coming from a hateful place.
MALE SPEAKER: A big
part of practice
is working on yourself,
and certainly, something
we hear from people that
take some of the classes
we have here is, like, wow.
It's a really amazing class.
And then sometimes when it
seems like when I go out
into the world,
it's an environment
that's a little hostile to that.
Particularly with
regard to compassion
practice, what are your thoughts
around the work with yourself
as it relates to other people?
Like, for instance, if
there's an impedance mismatch
between you and the
people around you,
how do you skillfully
negotiate that?
SHARON SALZBERG: You
mean in the sense
that people are not
responsive to your compassion?
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Or for instance,
you're operating
in a compassionate way, and
then maybe the group mores
are less compassionate.
SHARON SALZBERG: OK.
So what about if you're coming
from a compassionate place,
and the kind of culture
you're operating in
is not so much that way?
It happens, doesn't it?
I think we can-- again, going
back to what I was just saying,
I think it's clarifying
our intention, which
doesn't have to become the
lowest common denominator.
We don't have to live as driven
and confused as the people
around us may be.
And yet, there's more or less
skillful means of expression
that we do the best we
can to develop as skillful
a way of communicating
as possible.
So instead of saying, you're
all losers and you have no heart
and you're pathetic, there might
be a better way of saying that,
and really being very
truthful about that, but not
in a way that is [INAUDIBLE].
So for example, one of the
things I think about these days
is I really believe we live more
and more in a culture of being
taught that you will feel
better about yourself
by demeaning others, and that
if you can put others down,
you're going to feel better.
Years ago, a friend and I were
watching the Winter Olympics,
and this couple got up and
executed this dance on ice.
And then, the
instant they stopped,
it seemed like without
even drawing breath,
the commentator barked
out, lacks artistry.
And my friend I were like,
rolling on the floor.
It was like, give me a break.
These people just
danced on ice, you know?
That's not easy.
But it's just, that's how it is.
And I don't think we need to buy
into that, because the more we
live like that,
the more alone we
feel, threatened by
someone else's success,
even if it's not taking
anything away from us.
Like we're in
endless competition,
not just with people we're
competing with or against,
but we're constantly in this
state of feeling ripped off
by what someone
else is enjoying.
And it's not that fulfilling
or happy a place to be,
and we don't need
to buy into it.
But we don't need to be
condemning in a sort of nasty
way, like, I am the one who
understands how to speak
to people, whereas
you people don't.
But it actually
makes a difference.
I really believe in
a phrase I learned
from this group of women who
were running domestic violence
shelters that I was teaching,
where they themselves came up
with this phrase, a
culture of wellness,
that they wanted to start
to try to bring forth.
And I think it
makes a difference.
MALE SPEAKER: One of the things
about meditation practice
is that it can be really
useful during times
of emotional distress
or difficulty.
And I think that's
also the hardest
time to practice
in a lot of ways.
Like, let's really get
focused and pay attention
onto the degree of misery
I'm experiencing right now.
Any thoughts on being with
the practice during that time,
and in particular, any role
that compassion practice might
play in those sorts
of situations?
SHARON SALZBERG: Let's
look at the degree
of misery I'm
experiencing right now.
That's great.
I think there are a few things.
One is that's one
reason why I think
it's good to practice
in ordinary times.
It's like building up resources
and strength and capacity.
I was once interviewed for Good
Housekeeping Magazine, which
if you'd ever see
my house, you would
find as amusing as my friends.
It was really funny.
And my part of the
interview didn't make it
into the magazine.
Not because they saw my
house, but it just didn't.
So the question
was something like,
how do you use mindfulness
in a time of complete crisis?
And my answer was-- it was
one of those experiences where
you just hear words
come out your mouth,
so what I heard come out of
my mouth was, I wouldn't wait.
Like, don't wait.
Sometimes people do, and
even then, it can be useful.
But if you're just
having the ordinary day,
ordinary pressures,
whatever it might be,
that's the time to really be
building all of those skills.
Because you'll use them in much
more difficult times, and even
much more joyous times to
appreciate them and really
be there for them.
And so don't wait.
And if you have waited,
or you feel overcome,
even if you've gotten
experience and practice,
I think compassion
practice is a perfect thing
to do in those times.
Because it's very difficult
to extend compassion
toward ourselves.
That feels like weakness.
Like, somebody I was
teaching recently somewhere,
and I think even
that moment, like,
if you're doing
breath meditation,
where you have to let go of
the distraction and come back
is a moment of
compassion for yourself,
and forgiveness for yourself,
so you can start over.
And somebody really
objected to that,
and they said, well,
that's just being weak.
And if I forgive myself,
it's like giving myself
permission to do it again.
But I don't really think so.
I think if you do a kind
of thought experiment
about what that's like, you
make a mistake, you realize it,
you feel the pain or
discomfort of that,
you resolve to be different,
you let go, you go on.
That's one thing.
And to just go over it and
over it and over it and over it
and over it and over it
is not a really useful way
to have energy to go on.
So I don't know that it's going
to help us accomplish anything.
MALE SPEAKER: Your new book
is called "Happiness at Work."
And certainly, if you've seen
any of the studies or metrics
around happiness
in the workplace,
it's sort of a book
that needed writing.
One of the things that
is interesting to us,
and by interesting to
us, I mean something
that's hard and
challenging for us,
is the concept of
detaching from work.
I think a lot of people that
work here are very emotionally
invested in the work we do.
And I think working
here feels a lot
like working at
NASA in the 1960s.
Like, being at a
very special place
and time doing really cool work.
And it's not sustainable to be
doing email at 10:00, 11:00 at
night.
What's your take on the way
that practices can actually
support detaching
from work, even
if it's work that you love?
SHARON SALZBERG: I
think, first of all,
if it's work that you love,
you are very, very blessed.
It's a tremendous
blessing in one's life.
And still, we just need
some repose, you know?
Because in fact, we
are not our jobs.
I put that in the
book, which is actually
called "Real Happiness at Work."
And when I started doing
interviews for the book,
people were very
confounded by that.
Kind of like, what do you
mean, we're not our jobs?
Just like when I describe
myself at those parties,
somebody would say,
what do you do, right?
Which is what we say instead
of what makes you happy,
or what was your favorite
experience of the week?
It's like, what do you do?
We're all taught to
identify with that role.
And it's great to be invested,
and I think to really care.
And it's not all that we are.
And so I think even just
ritualizing whatever
it might be-- it's like the
great experiment of life.
I'm not going to check
email after whenever.
I just quoted Linda Stone
in coining the phrase email
apnea, which is
very interesting.
Check it out next time
you're doing email.
Are you breathing?
Isn't it interesting
that there's actually
a thing like that, where our
breath can get so shallow when
we're doing email that we are
barely breathing, with all
the attendant
consequences of that?
Ritualizing pauses.
Stepping back.
Taking a breath during the
day, or periods of time
where we're not constantly on,
just to have a better balance.
MALE SPEAKER: Something
else in the book
that I thought was really
relevant to this group
is also the idea, or maybe
the myth of multitasking.
What ways do you
think mindfulness
can support being involved less
in-- it's called multitasking,
but fast and inefficient
context switching.
SHARON SALZBERG:
Ooh, I like that.
Fast and inefficient
context switching.
Well, as I'm sure
you know, studies
show that, in fact,
when we're multitasking,
we're not that
effective and efficient,
which is why we do it.
We think it's really
going bring us far.
And I think one of
things about mindfulness
exercises that you can
bring into your workplace
or into your life is that
they can seem very simplistic,
but they actually work.
Just like ritualizing
that pause or that moment
before taking action.
Like, when I was first living
in India, nobody had a job,
and people weren't
raising families then,
and we weren't really
doing anything.
But still, it was
not that easy to have
a practice during conversation
or in the visa office
or whatever it was.
And so we would always ask our
teachers, what should we do?
And the recommendations I
thought were so simplistic.
Like, feel your feet
against the floor,
or take a breath before you
respond to the visa officer.
And I'd think, that's so stupid.
But actually doing it
makes a difference.
Look at that.
Things like Thich Nhat
Hanh's famous suggestion,
don't pick up the phone
on the first ring.
Let it ring three
times and breathe.
It's not going to take
such a huge amount of time,
but it just helps you come
back, and then you start again.
So in terms of mindfulness
and multitasking,
it might be just
one thing, you know?
Like drink a cup of tea or
coffee, and just do that.
It's not going to take forever.
You don't have to worry about
not getting your list done.
But rather than drink the cup
of tea and check your email
and be on the conference
call and have something else
going on at the same
time, take a few moments
and just do that fully,
and see what happens.
AUDIENCE: As a follow
up to one or both
of those last
questions, we talk a lot
about getting into flow
experiences at work,
and you end up getting totally
absorbed in what you're doing.
And it almost seems like
that's a very different skill
and a different experience
to being mindful.
And I'm wondering is there
such a thing as too much flow?
How do you balance
flow and mindfulness?
MALE SPEAKER: Mm-hm.
SHARON SALZBERG: So how do you
balance flow and mindfulness?
I think they're
actually connected
in that mindfulness doesn't need
to be, and as it's practiced,
it doesn't need to be so labored
or stylized or effortful.
It really becomes
this kind of flow.
And I also think that
sometimes what we think
is flow is just kind
of a distraction
if it's not born out of a
kind of attention or interest
or some powerful passion
for what we're doing.
Then, you know, we're
just kind of drifting,
but we think it's--
Like, we often use this example
as a joke of a typical 5
or 10 or 15 minutes
in a meditator's mind,
where you're sitting, and
maybe you're with the breath,
and then you think, I wonder
where I should go for dinner.
And then you think,
well, you know,
it would be good to
get a vegetarian meal.
I mean, I spent
the whole afternoon
meditating, and after all--
And then you think,
you know, I think
I'll be a vegetarian
from now on.
That would be really healthy,
and it's better for the planet,
and it's more in line
with my moral values.
And then you think,
you know, it's
hard to be a vegetarian
without really knowing
how to be a good
cook, because you
have to eat out all the time.
You don't get good food.
So I better really
learn how to cook.
And then you think, what time
does that bookstore close?
Maybe I can run
there and I can buy
all these vegetarian
cookbooks, and then I
could be a great vegetarian
because I'm a great cook.
And then you think, while
I'm in the bookstore,
I think I'll go to
the travel section,
because I need to find a book
to plan my next vacation.
Like, should I go to Mexico?
Should I go to Canada?
Oh, I know.
Now I'm a vegetarian
and I meditate.
I'll go to India.
And we kind of wake up walking
down the streets of New Delhi,
and the last thing
remember thinking
is, I wonder where I should
go for dinner, right?
So we've kind of
floated away on that sea
of associative thinking.
But it's not really the
same thing, of course,
as a flow state, which is
much more completely unified.
And so we need mindfulness,
I think, almost
to know the difference.
And mindfulness will move
into that more and more.
AUDIENCE: So is this working?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
during periods of my life,
I've had a couple
periods of my life
where I've been much better
about mindfulness, and even
[INAUDIBLE] short periods.
And one of my concerns I've had
is that it sort of cultivates
this level of what I call
softness in myself that almost
doesn't feel like it has
a place in my work life.
Like, almost that
sort of softness,
if I was to bring
it to my work life,
I'd feel very vulnerable in
a way that doesn't feel OK.
So I'm wondering if that
makes any sense to you,
or if you have
any advice for how
to navigate that
potential fear I have.
SHARON SALZBERG: So
you feel that kind
of softness or vulnerability
in terms of relationships
with others, or that you
would be too revealing?
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think that maybe
based on models I see around
me, it just seems so different.
And some of the way I
sometimes want to carry myself
seem so different from
what I see in pop culture
and what I see in
other companies,
for example, that I
just feel abnormal.
It feels like it would
be abnormal to bring
that kind of tone.
I try to anyway,
but I don't know.
I guess it's a fear that I have
based on a cognition of what's
expected in the
modern work world.
SHARON SALZBERG:
Well, I think, yes, it
can be really, really
tough, and for people
who work here, obviously,
you're very lucky, you know?
But I think it's
also interesting.
Sometimes it's
interesting to be brave
and just to see what
happens, and how much of it
is our own apprehension
and how much of it--
again, things need
to be expressed
as skillfully as possible.
But sometimes, I mean,
I've seen that situation
in different kinds of settings,
and in some surprising ways.
Sometimes there is actually
gratitude that happens.
I mean, again, not
if you're preachy,
and not if you're losing an edge
of creativity or engagement.
But you don't have to.
You can be coming from
a different place.
And I've just seen
lots of times when
someone in a group,
a collective,
is really grateful for
somebody pointing out, like,
just the being.
Maybe we don't have to do that,
or I don't have to do that,
or I can't bear to
do that, you know?
In some way, I'm going to
have to try it in this way,
or try this direction.
That's how things
change, really,
is, I think, by one person
being able to be authentic
in some way.
MALE SPEAKER: To
add to that, also,
I think that being vulnerable
and displaying vulnerability
is something you can play with
from a leadership perspective.
Strategic use of vulnerability
can be really powerful, right?
You don't want to come over like
a shambling wreck, you know?
But to actually let
someone behind the scenes,
even in a leadership position,
is extraordinarily powerful
if you do it strategically.
So advice would be, look for
opportunities to, particularly
with people you feel safe for,
to play with that edge, right?
And you may find out
that the censorship
is coming more from inside.
Like, the call is
from inside the house,
rather than what the
reaction of other people
would necessarily be.
I got a fun one.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So
one of the reasons
why I'm so grateful that Sharon
is spending the afternoon
with us is if you look
at what's going on with,
like, mindfulness and
meditation and some of you
may be going to Wisdom 2.0 this
weekend, or saw Time Magazine,
or maybe even friends or
relatives are you asking
about this thing, if they
know you're into it--
it wasn't always that way.
It's a really recent phenomenon.
And one of the things I'm
very grateful for for Sharon
is she's one of the OG,
original gangsters, who
took these practices in the late
'60s, early '70s, and thought,
wow, these might
actually work in the US.
And I think, actually, to arrive
at that conclusion in 1971
is sort of a hell of a thing.
And especially to be here.
So could you have imagined?
It's 1971.
Everyone's wearing bellbottoms,
sideburns, big hair, that one
day, that mindfulness would
be sort of the buzz word?
And what do you think are
the positives of that,
and what are some of
the negatives of that?
And how does it feel?
Like, what's that like?
Oh, and also, thank you for
doing that whole bringing it
here thing.
SHARON SALZBERG: Oh,
yeah, you're welcome.
I got a new phrase.
OG.
MALE SPEAKER: OG.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah, OG.
Original gangster.
Wow.
No, I never, ever, ever
would have imagined.
None of us did.
And I have to say, honestly,
that our coming back-- well, I
told you the story about Di
Pama telling me to teach.
It wasn't like we had a
strategic plan, or even much
of a vision.
We-- Joseph Goldstein,
Jack Kornfield,
and I began teaching
together, and we
would respond to
invitations, and somebody
would write and say,
I can get together
some friends and a cook.
Will you come teach a retreat?
And we'd teach that retreat.
And at the end of
the retreat, we never
knew if there would
be another retreat.
And then another
letter would come.
And one day, someone
else suggested
we start the retreat center--
the Insight Meditation
Society-- and we did.
We moved in on
Valentine's Day of 1976.
And honestly, our mantra
for the entire first year
was, we can always
close in a year.
We'll just close it in a year.
If it doesn't work, and no one
wants learn how to meditate,
we'll just close it in a year.
And we couldn't get a mortgage.
The property, which, have any
of you been there, by the way?
AUDIENCE: In Barre?
SHARON SALZBERG: Yes.
It's a great retreat center
in Barre, Massachusetts.
And it's a big building.
It was an [INAUDIBLE]
when we bought it,
so it's kind of like this
institutional building that
can sleep about 100
retreatants plus staff.
About 20 staff people.
And 80 acres of
land, and it cost us
$150,000 in 1976,
which we didn't have.
So we raised $50,000.
The Fathers of the
Blessed Sacrament,
which were running it, they
gave us a $50,000 mortgage,
and we couldn't get a
mortgage from the bank.
So these three people
had to personally cosign
a loan for the money
for the other $50,000,
and so they didn't like it
much when we kept saying,
we can close it in a year.
We can just close it
in a year, because they
would have lost their money.
But we didn't know.
I mean, there was no sense.
And it really wasn't strategic.
The practices had meant
so much to each of us,
and it seemed like an
the important thing
to try to convey, and
retreats were tiny,
and we were grateful
anybody showed up.
And very slowly, things
really began to change.
I never would have
imagined this.
And I think it's great.
I think that if people are going
to reach for something to try
to make their lives better,
or the situation around them
better, like, why not, you know?
It's a series of skills.
And I am very method oriented,
as you can probably tell.
And one of the
reasons is because I
think that's what sets us free.
It's like, the method is
what we can do on our own,
and really develop and cultivate
this kind of understanding.
And I think it's terrific.
And it's going to be everything.
It's already everything,
from ashtrays to whatever.
It's everything.
And there are
people who are going
to practice for all kinds
of different reasons.
I mean, that was an
interesting question,
which we started
talking about earlier.
When I wanted to learn how to
practice, I was 18 years old.
I was going to school
in Buffalo, New York,
and I had to get
myself to India.
So that was a strong motivation
to really learn a practice.
I had done a lot of internal
work just in getting to India,
and moving.
I'd never even
been to California
when I went to India.
And these days, you
don't have to have
that kind of really
intense motivation.
You just have to
go to a bookstore
or have a friend
who heard about it,
or worked in a certain place.
And it's going to be different.
So it's very intriguing just to
see how we'll it will evolve.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
So speaking of bookstores, some
of the folks from the East West
Bookstore in Mountain
View are in the back,
and they have copies of
Sharon's book available,
as well as some other ones.
And it's my understanding
that in addition to
offering this wisdom in
the form of dead trees,
that you can also purchase
electronic versions
for your readers there.
So if that's of interest
to you, it's right there.
With that--
SHARON SALZBERG: I think so.
MALE SPEAKER: So, hey,
thank you all so much.
It was really great
to have an opportunity
to spend an afternoon of
practice and chatting.
And I hope it was
valuable for you.
And thank you very much,
and thank you, Sharon.
Thank you, Lindsay, for
putting this all together,
and thank you guys for coming.
[APPLAUSE]